Queen Elizabeth is tapping into the
sparkling wine industry she least had a
small chunk of land on her estate
outside Windsor Castle for vineyard
while the wine from those grapes sold
out in its first two years of release
CBS News was the first US Network
allowed inside the vineyard at Windsor
Grand Park Charlie d'Agata spoke with
those trusted with the high profile
responsibility of producing wine on the
Queensland it might look like a scene
from the sunnier climes of France but it
doesn't get any more British than this
because this modest little vineyard
happens to be in the backyard of one of
Britain's biggest landowners the Queen
frankly Her Majesty could spare seven
acres on grounds that span more than
15,000 acres on her estate outside
Windsor Castle around 20 miles west of
London there have been a couple of
bunches on that the man who helped plant
the idea and the vines for that matter
winemaker Tony lathe wait that's peanut
oil really nice you could call Tony a
next-door neighbor he grew up in the
town of Windsor and thought this patch
of prime real estate just might work I
was enthusiastic because I thought winds
a great part yes--that's Wow
yes there's several places in there I
could immediately think of I mean I know
the place pretty well oh yes the Queen
was enthusiastic too as was husband
Prince Philip who's held the title of
Ranger of Windsor Great Park for 65
years a great honor that we've been able
to do this but we know we're being
watched we have to do it really well you
get a pretty important boss yes the land
and the climate best suited sparkling
wine it's champagne in all but name that
belongs to the French and the region
champagne but the vines came from
champagne the chalky soil is similar
it's processed exactly the same way and
at 45 bucks a bottle costs about the
same as champagne to a southerly facing
field gets more of the sunlight and once
all those grapes are gathered tomorrow
Roberts is in charge of fermenting
bottling and distribution no pressure
the grapes are grown here then the rest
is down to you that's right
huge responsibility Gosha yeah we
obviously understand how high-profile
this this particular vineyard is the
Crown has joined a craze in British
sparkling wine in the last decade
vineyard acreage has grown by an
astonishing 135 percent something wine
producers put down to warmer
temperatures climbing north if you
compare where we are today to where
champagne was 30 years ago that's pretty
much where we were weather-wise and it
gives us the opportunity to have a
slightly longer growing season makes it
feasible in order to grow the grapes
that week we can this year's first
vintage just three thousand bottles were
snapped up even now there are pre orders
including orders to the US but is it any
good wine expert Hugh Johnson it is good
it's not as good as it will be the raw
material is very good and when the vines
are a bit older it'll be very good
indeed
for Tony lathe wait the person he wanted
to impress most was the Queen herself
when we presented the first bottles that
was a day if only my mother could have
seen me look who I'm giving this bottle
to though just a walk away it was a
world away from where he grew up and
that is worth raising a glass to for CBS
this morning Charlie d'Agata Windsor
Great Park England well cheers to that
you think the Queen's out there picking
grapes I wonder if she comes up but I
love that he said at the end if only my
mother could see me see we always want
to make our parents Liz's fizz is what
the Daily Mail called it